coinbase CEO Brian Armstrong is in a
battle with Regulators the SEC sued his
company saying coinbase broke the rules
by listing tokens that the regulator
alleges are subject to Securities laws
he sat down with the journal to discuss
the situation this doesn't seem like one
where there's a lot of dispute about the
facts you're trading cryptocurrencies on
coinbase the question really is are you
breaking the law and is what you are
trading a security what's your
interpretation of the law basically
we're in this environment of you know
regulation by enforcement I don't feel
like there's a clear rule book The only
sort of high-level statements they've
made is that everything other than
Bitcoin is a security which that's just
that's just not what it says in the law
and by the way that would also kind of
mean like the end of the crypto industry
in the US if that was actually the you
know what happened and so we have to go
to court to challenge that we're proud
to do it for the industry and for
America but this has been something that
has been hanging over the industry and
coinbase for a while you and your S1
when you file to go public put down as a
risk the SEC he may decide that the
stuff that we are trading is in fact a
security but you pushed ahead anyway and
built a business and grew that business
and added more tokens and added more
assets tell us why you did that well
there are certainly crypto Securities
out there in fact um coinbase has
reviewed you know well over a thousand
different assets ninety percent of them
we've rejected the 10 or less of assets
that we've reviewed that we did decide
to list we feel that those are crypto
Commodities and so
um you know they don't need to be
registered and traded with under an SEC
license so the question of what is a
security to zoom way out you've got like
baseball cards at one end you've got
Apple stock on the other end right
baseball cards clearly not a security we
trade baseball cards they have value but
nobody thinks that like uh you know 1987
tops Daryl strawberry is a security
Apple stock clearly a security big gap
between those things and the SEC is
making arguments that a bunch of things
that you trade on coinbase are more over
here closer to Apple how do you think
about that distinction there is this
thing called the Howie test right which
which is the definition of a security
and it kind of says you know is there an
investment of money in a common
Enterprise with an expectation of profit
based on the effort of others so it has
those kind of four prongs the important
thing to know is that it all in all four
of those things have to be true right so
there's various ways that you know you
could imagine
um a crypto asset uh would not be a
security right if it's if it's
sufficiently decentralized there's no
common Enterprise right if there's some
specific utility around it it's not
specifically it's not just for the
purpose of you know the value of going
up right and so what we need in the
United States at this point is
regulatory Clarity so you looked at
thousands or a thousand
tokens you listed 250 ish of them and
the SEC has a problem with 13 at least
13 but they highlight 13. so but the
issue is you have to bad thousand right
you can't have any
Securities you've got to have all 250
that you trade can't be Securities
otherwise you're running an unlicensed
Securities Exchange and an unlicensed
Clearinghouse and an unlicensed broker
so it seems like the the odds are kind
of not in your favor
so that's not really how I think of it
remember we've been the goal of our this
lawsuit is to get clarity for the
industry right and we've actually been
formally petitioning the SEC for Clear
well the goal the SEC the sec's goal is
to stop you from
from breaking the law in their view it's
not I don't think they think that
there's a lack of clarity in the
industry I think they think that you're
breaking the law
well that may be what they say but you
know I can assure you there's a huge
lack of clarity but I we feel strongly
all the ones that we listed there since
we took a pretty conservative approach
they are they are Commodities the SEC
says in its complaint that you rush that
process how do you respond to that I
feel pretty comfortable about the the
analysis the irony of this is that we
were continuously asking them during
this period
um can you give us more clarity that
like that's how it's supposed to work
you you have taken I think it's fair to
say a reasonably confrontational
approach for the SEC there's some
there's a Twitter thread in which you
said some sketchy things going on do you
regret that approach
well I wouldn't say our approach has
been confrontational it is with great
you know we've never relished the
opportunity or the idea of like ending
up in litigation with our regulator in
fact quite the opposite and by the way
you know I have a greater deal of
respect for
um the people at the SEC the staff the
Commissioners I think our relationship
with the chair has been quite difficult
honestly but there's a lot of really
good people at the SEC and we've had no
issue working with every other regulator
out there both in the US but also
internationally why is the why is the
relationship with chair Gensler been
difficult
you know I I don't know I don't want to
speculate on his motives or or anything
like that but um
you know when I when he first came into
the role um I made an effort to kind of
fly out there and go meet with him
I don't know why the schedules wouldn't
align
um we made several attempts we
eventually did get to meet but only
virtually over have you ever had a
one-on-one meeting in person with him
I've never been able to meet with him in
person which is which is rare what is
sort of Brian Armstrong's dream
regulatory structure for crypto well so
the first one is we just need to get
some clarity about the market structure
and how you know the cfdc and the SEC
are both going to regulate this industry
what are the boundaries I think we also
need to just bring in some basic
consumer protections it's actually not
rocket science this is just applying
some of these really basic Common Sense
ideas
um to the industry and then once we have
that legislation in place
I think we'll start to see some of the
entrepreneurs who've left the US come
back and say okay I feel that we're not
just going to be attacked randomly or
have incredibly High legal bills at any
given moment and we can actually build a
business here in the US again